6 14 on a wednesday morning checking gas
prices it's a repetitive and frustrating
part of everyday life the cost of
filling up keeps going up but at least
we know there's usually a station around
when we really need it i went to a place
where that's not always the case
death valley national park an entire
part of the world built on extremes the
cool tree covered mountains the barren
scalding hot valley floor ready dotted
with travelers looking to feel the heat
nothing is more extreme than the
temperature in death valley sea and
experience yeah
the park thermometer in furnace creek
always captures the eye then you can say
you've been to like the hottest place
and it definitely is like indescribably
hot i can't believe you're wearing
trousers aside from commenting on this
reporter's attire visitors couldn't miss
the other extreme number in death valley
right now there's nearly nine dollars
here oh you gotta be kidding me the
price of gas 716
is kinda high
fuel is always expensive here but now
it's rivaling the temperature is the
most shocking number worth seeing oh
well to fill up it would have cost two
hundred dollars death valley has just
two stations the stovepipe wells spot is
owned by the park service so it's cheap
on this day 7 16 a gallon
this spot in furnace creek though is
privately owned and more than a full
dollar more it's ridiculous
[Music]
it's not gonna get us far we just put in
ten dollars because we're scared of
breaking down and running out of petrol
for road trippers like the heat the high
cost of gas was expected knew that you
were going to be spending a lot of time
you know
driving and so the expense it was
figured out the extreme heat though you
can leave behind the extreme expense
that stays with you well beyond death
valley see no it's not even going down
if only she was saying that about the
gas prices
if you visit death valley it's only a
couple hours from las vegas of course
most of us will fill up in pahrump
before venturing into the park so if you
haven't been there before top off before
you go over into california gas is a lot
cheaper in prompt and it's about an hour
from the the edge of the park there so
yeah it's a little cooler in peru too
not by much but it is a little bit